hi i'm piccola and today i'm super
excited to talk about delivering high
performing global apis with apogee and
cloud cdn
with the power of digital many
organizations across industries are
going global
to unlock new markets and optimize costs
as
businesses expand their global
footprints they need to deliver
connected customer experiences integrate
seamlessly with regional partners
and equip global distributed workforces
apis are packages of data and
functionality that power
digital experiences both customer facing
and employee facing
therefore as you go global it is
imperative to scale your api
programs to help you globalize your api
initiatives
google cloud brings together apogee and
cloud cdn the best of api management
and content delivery network solutions
while apigee builds a solid foundation
for your apis
cloud cdm brings you the same edge
points of presence that google uses to
serve its
web properties to billions of users
by extending the power of cloud cd into
your apis
you can host your apis across 24 regions
and 73 zones
reduce the latency of your apis with
caching at more than 100 locations
and increase the availability for peak
traffic seasons
let's see a quick demo of how this works
for the purpose of this demo i've
created a hello world api in apigee
to protect this api let's first start by
adding a verify api key to this proxy
once we do that you'll see the default
is set to a query param
but let's change this to a header
i'm now going to save it as a new
revision
and deploy it to the demo environment
to consume this api let's create an api
product and add our api proxy to this
product by specifying the path
with this the hello world proxy is now
ready and accessible
now let's see how to apply cloud cdn to
improve the caching of this api to
better serve global consumers
i created a very simple cloud cdn policy
and attached it to a load balancer i
also picked the most basic configuration
for this policy
when i go to the load balancer you can
see that cloud cdn is enabled
i need to make one minor addition to my
api proxy to let cloud cdn know
the response of this api needs to be
cached
when i access the proxy from us west the
call is executed in about 10
milliseconds
if i take the same call and execute it
from a vm located in europe west
the response time for this first attempt
is about 215 milliseconds
however because of enhanced caching the
response time for the second attempt
goes down to 16 milliseconds
that was just a quick preview of how to
deliver high performing global apis with
apogee and cloud cdn
in summary apogee and cloud cdn offer
integrated out of the box capabilities
to scale and deliver
high performing apis now it's your turn
to try it out and get started by
following the links in the description
box below
you